how's it going everybody so we have some
news today it seems like a character
that has died in a previous Marvel movie
is going to be making an appearance and
Avengers for this leak is very legit so
if you don't want any spoilers for
Avengers 4 here's your warning
the giveaway still continues I'm giving
away copies of infinity war and ant-man
and the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero I'll be picking
another winner this weekend so this
character that will be briefly coming
back and Avengers 4 is actually from
Captain America and that character is
Brock rumlow or also known as crossbones
Frank Grillo who is the actor that plays
crossbones in the movies was recently on
the UFC unfiltered podcast and during
the podcast he revealed that his
character will be returning in Avengers
4 frank grillo says crossbow makes an
appearance in the next Avengers movie
but it's a flashback he then goes on to
say yeah I'm allowed to say whatever I
want because I'm never doing another
Marvel movie this is exciting news to
some because many fans were very
disappointed to see crossbones killed
off so fast in the beginning of Captain
America Civil War Brock rumlow just
adopted the crossbones persona and it
seems like Marvel sort of just wasted a
villain by killing him off so fast so
crossbones will be returning in a
flashback but keep in mind Marvel is
very secretive they don't like any
potential spoilers getting out somehow
and they don't give the full script to
all the actors that are in the movie
especially ones that are playing minor
roles so in the script that Frank Grillo
got what seems to be a flashback could
very well be time travel and it would
actually make a lot of sense if it is
time-travel
if our heroes are going back in time and
trying to change some events of the past
it would make sense that they would go
back to that time during Captain America
Civil War where Captain America and
crossbones fought and they could keep
the Scarlet Witch from blowing up the
building this would actually prevent the
sokovia accords from happening and in
doing so the avengers would never split
up and if they never split up they could
take on Thanos together all of them at
the same time and they just might have a
chance then so that kind of line
sup if they go back to the events of
Civil War where Captain America and
crossbones fought it's at that exact
moment the explosion that eventually
leads to the Avengers breaking up so
stopping that from happening could keep
the Avengers together so although Frank
Grillo says it's a flashback it could
very well be time-travel but what do you
all think do you think it's a flashback
or do you think it's time travel and
either way are you excited to see
crossbones back on screen again let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date with
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]